the challenge of making a midsize sedan  is standing out from the crowd kia  however has never had that problem this  is a 2016 kia optima and it is once  again a looker sketched under the  watchful eye of a former audi designer  the Optima has been taking the sedan  segment by storm us sales have almost  doubled in three years a pace no  competitors matched not Toyota's Camry  not Honda's accord and not Ford's fusion  the 2016 version looks even sporty-er  it's slightly wider it's a little bit  longer and it has a more aggressive  grille kia has also added an 8-inch  touchscreen in the dash acoustic  laminated glass and a seventh year to go  with its dual clutch transmission that's  right the Optima by all accounts a safe  conservative car choice has paddle  shifters come fall Kia customers will be  able to choose an Optima with one of  three different engines and in five  different trims from standard to  luxurious they look about the same but  that's not a bad thing